tous et bienvenue à l'heure des
problèmes qui fait rêver les femmes du
groupe canal+ ah si j'ai regardé à
l'autre jour j'ai le droit de dire ça
monsieur fenech j'ai regardé monsieur
hanouna l'autre jeu
bien sûr et sur le jeu des fennecs
bonjour a vite fait normal qu'ils
s'appellent greffier du charisme
pourquoi pas le sex-appeal peut-être il
ya quelque chose chez vous qui qui fait
que cette jeune femme vous a déclaré en
direct sa flamme à l'antenne
c'est sur ces terrains ça n'est pas une
parodie s'il devrait pas qu'à procès
devrait georges fenech la demeurer en
dix ans
la meute comme quoi il a une vieille
télévision
[Rires]
cryptée
côté daniel comme moi vous l'avez vu
georges
et émoustiller est pas complètement
indifférent à votre charme
avec un grand c comme cassoulet
daniel est ce que vous êtes toujours
amoureuse de george est en fait je ne
peux je ne regarde plus libres
d'enseignants quand il est là parce que
ça me fait trop de mal je regarde
patrick lagnel un message pour toi
george daniels un message pour toi
en fait je rêve de vous et je suis en
train de devenir votre cauchemar je m'en
rends bien compte donc je suis désolé
mais pour l'instant ça ne passe pas pour
l'instant mon coeur bat toujours pour
vous et votre sex apeal
meuron électrique
[Applaudissements]
on sait que sa pile électrique j'espère
capa et le voir les pieds dans l'eau
c'est avec s'électrocuter
sait jamais un accident est vite arrivé
daniel est très sérieusement que tu
aimes toujours georges
c'est une plaie ouverte pour l'instant
elle a écouté les thés bus daniele righi
savez qu'il ya quelqu'un dans sa vie
est ce que pendant qu'elle tremble avec
la concurrence mais pourquoi
est ce que ça vous fait peur ben non ça
me fait pas peur parce que les couples
ça va ça vient oui
danel passant toute la france est
derrière moi
daniel
[Musique]
est ce que vous pensez que vous pouvez
la chasse et sasha sait pas qui va à la
chasse perd sa place
non mais moi je veux pas non si un jour
par malheur il est seul jeu alors on
comptait pas comme ça on se bat oui on
se bat croyez moi quand je veux et voilà
à moi moi je me battrai ouais voilà vous
voyez vous pourriez vous battre pour
quelqu'un qui est déjà en couple
oui oui
elle vous arrête quoi l'amour narrateur
c'est pas gentil ouais bah c'est pas
gentil c'est parce que j'en ai à [ __ ]
ce n'est pas ce gars là rationnel ne
connais pas la connais pas lisse qu'elle
en a [ __ ] paddy lowe talent a rien à
[ __ ] non mais
la mur par l'amour des livres à la
poutre
daniel profession m
me battrai jusqu'au bout tout les
mégane gr jean michel aulas si elle
était là si elle était là à la map de
genre québécois
battrai jusqu'au bout j'ai peu d'armes
mais j'irai jusqu'au bout on s'en fout
je suis près de là tout voilà dessous
[Applaudissements]
comment s'est fait ce qu'elle dit
horloge dit je sais que georges à
quelqu'un mais au fond lui c'est que je
peux être une vraie biatch
alors non je salaire est à tous et
laniel sachez que n'ai pas besoin de
regarder la caméra arrête puisque la
compagne de george
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai c'est pas faux bail après
bye c'est vrai si je vais me battre
alors merci d'être là je voulais savoir
comment il s'appelle mais je veux le
sait comment marie
exercice avait
au plus tard
c'est bien vous n'avez pas ce qu'on voit
qu'il ya des similitudes physiques
motors céderait s'il me faire le grand
écart
était ya pas ébranlé carcela dubaï merci
marine est là j'ai vraiment un
argentique et marié envie de venir
on peut certes un amour parce que vous
avez en face de vous une deux plus
grands rivaux plus grande rivale et vous
le prenez avec le sourire ce n'est pas
la seule non c'est pas la seule à cause
d'elle maintenant fait encore pire
qu'avant ah bah oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'à cause de vous parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a mis la lumière sur georges
moi je savais qu'ils étaient magnifiques
vraiment il est beau il est intelligent
il ya tout pour lui vous avez vous avez
énormément de chance c'est l'ami des
halles est ce que vous comptez
peut-être vous êtes passé un moment
[Rires]
avec eux je suis venu et je ne fais pas
que je suis là non
nombreux genres un amour de mec est
vraiment je suis fan de lui il est
excellent et lyonnais depuis lors et les
jeux et je comprends c'est vrai que vous
êtes magnifique vous êtes souriante et
sympathique mais malheureusement
quelques quelqu'un en veut à votre nom
est-ce que non mais qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire à daniel est ce que je peux être
pouvait devenir amis bah oui
cela dit je suis pas une femme jalouse
c'est les méchants qui sont jaloux c'est
vrai mais cela dit j'aimerais bien que
ça s'arrête un peu quand même parce que
moi j'étais au travail tranquillement et
je salue mon équipe d'agneau sécurité
d'ailleurs qui ont été un grand soutien
pour moi moi c'est parce que
ce soir là je reçois des messages de
partout georgette en direct avec daniel
mon nom je me suis dit qu'est ce qui se
passe georges est quelqu'un de discret
en général et l'état trop people et je
me suis demandé après c'est quelqu'un de
bon donc les gens
c'est un gentleman c'est vrai et dans la
vie aussi et voilà mais en attendant
donnez moi j'existe je suis là et vous
c'est à dire ce qu'il a déjà du succès
alors si en plus on en rajoute tous les
jours c'est plein de messages en disant
meta bon goût il et il est magnifique et
oui mais moi aussi j'ai en tête
[Applaudissements]
je
pense que tu des comprendra mieux
à de nous casser les couilles à faire
parce que je t'explique ça va se
terminer partout
je tenais tu vas donc elle le fait voilà
donc tu vous avez parlé je vais décrire
je vais traduire ce que vous dites ils
ont dit à daniel ce que vous avez à lui
dire la pauvre en fait à kaunas
[Applaudissements]
c'est la traduction c'est la cre a des
choses
c'est vrai que c'était dur au début
après je suis quand même fier que mon
âme attire des fans de qualité pour
traduire même charmante c'est vrai qu'au
début ça me faisait rien c'est vrai que
là ça commence vraiment à me casser les
grèves
et continuez donc j'aimerais bien que ça
s'arrête un petit peu donc j'en reviens
tu fermes ta et le jeu
[Applaudissements]
elle marie est prévu cette gentillesse
et
son mari vous méritez genre genre je
vous mérite merci c'est ce que je
retiens maintenant on attend attend
définis quand même
[Musique]
à temps la ola
j'ai pas qui s'est déchargé pas ces gens
non c'est ça je ne sais pas qui est ce
numéro je crois que c'est un prétendant
également jean alesi continuer ouais
c'est qui banel
quelqu'un qui a raccroché
signifie cette mal car je me suis donné
c'était pas à vendre alors daniel
peut-être que marie a peut-être
quelqu'un te présenter oui il y en a
brisé des chroniqueurs des conclusions
sur ses news il va y avoir un
célibataire alors c'est est-ce que tu as
kaka en tête est-ce que j'ai quelqu'un
en tête de ces news dans deux de partout
en france et de la france vous passez
maintenant tout est jeune on a plein de
copains ne saurait compenser des ventes
et daniel et bien sûr voila voila tu
vois bah c'est bien j'essaierai de
l'oublier
terminé
6ème et sarah cauchon apprendre beaucoup
c'est comme si tous les jours il ya un
mec qui disait je pécho pas tout
vous aimez moi j'ai jamais dit ça non
mais on sait que la pâte ou à les
avances son problème
est qu'il ne vit très bien là bas un à
voir mais mon mari mange pas que ce
n'est pas la vérité est là tout vous
aussi vous avez je n'ai rien
une charnière
a rencontré avant moi autrement vous
n'avez
un sommet qui t'est jamais
[Applaudissements]
seul timing c'est ça daniel l'important
c'est que peut-être que vous allez
trouver l'amour grâce grâce à nous ah ça
c'est très possible puisque peut-être
que ça va se décanter peut-être qu'ils
vont vous présenter quelqu'un n'a pas de
frère n'a pas de frein fait violer par
cosa
oui imposant attention elle cherche
quelqu'un mais voilà deux mobiles vivant
[Rires]
jeudi les chanteurs voilà et qui aime la
vie et à qui voilà
s'éclater à royan tous les étés y
soit le problème eh bien on va s'occuper
de vous êtes en amour
[Applaudissements]